it's software's doom is returning this
may but it's not just one big
single-player campaign full of kakoe
demons and arch files publisher Bethesda
has revealed the warpath multiplayer
mode in which capture points move in a
set path around the arena while a
powerup moves along the opposite path
it's kind of like king of the hill but
with a twist the blog post stated
players have to decide where they want
to be rushing toward the power up to
turn into a marine destroying demon
clustered around the capture point to
defender steal control or simply roaming
around looking to pick off any errant
foes the constant motion adds a unique
twist to the gameplay spring players to
move just as quickly as they do in
single-player Bethesda teased more than
just warpath mode revealing new items
called hack modules these are single-use
items that can give you a hand by
spotting enemy players displaying
powerup locations and even marking the
last player who killed you the publisher
stressed that these are not micro
transactions you'll learn them as you
play the game Doom hits ps4 xbox one and
pc on May thirteenth a beta will also
take place at some point before launch
though we don't know when that will
happen but if you want to stay up to
date on all the latest doom news you're
ready in the right place
you